greetings from podcast Ville its Monday
the 30th of December that's it
[ __ ]
this is the last Monday how the [ __ ] you
gonna act the church what's happening
now is brought to you by our next
sponsor is one of my favorites
why because I believe in hygiene and I
believe if you don't have a clean ass
butt type of person are you got no
[ __ ] character you understand me the
bidet is the hello tissue bidet is
something you install at home takes 10
minutes and it changes your whole life
you like Joey what type of life changing
experience I'm talking of type you'll
take your wife and throw out the [ __ ]
window because she's not necessary
anymore
this is hot water cleaning your ass
you're walking around all day nice and
clean little pep in your step
how old till she comes in different
colors and they started $79 if you get
in this mess podcast right now it's
never too late to give somebody how old
is she never never you know why cuz
everybody's ass smells like a [ __ ]
dead Egyptian that's why so do yourself
a favor stop killing trees stop using
[ __ ] dirty to you this is the same
water you brush your teeth with this
ain't that toilet water your ass I was
gonna be tip-top Magoo got ahold - she
got time right now I'm pressing Church
and get 10% off your order all right the
church is also brought to you want one
of my personal favorites and since you
want to start the year off on a good
foot this is the way to start the new
year off alpha brain shroom tech sport
shroom tech top immune kettlebells Club
bells on it's got everything for you you
understand me that's why I do business
with them that's why they've been a
sponsor of the show for seven years
who else takes a product stands behind
it and if you don't like it don't give
you your money back million ask
questions that's on it that's why I do
business with them they're running a
contest you buy some alpha brain you get
a lottery ticket they enter you you win
you get the other experience two days
you eat the barbecue or B gives you G
note you get some clothing you get a
year supply listen it's on and on and on
but it starts with alpha brain go to
Anna comrade now press in church and get
10%
if you order delivered to your door
right there that's how you start off mm
[ __ ] 20 kick this [ __ ] mule
leak it's Monday morning the Church of
what's happened now it's myself and Lee
we're just doing a quick wrap-up show
not to leave you out there [ __ ]
hanging everybody else's leaving town
and whatnot listen thank you very much
for a good year I don't know what type
of year you had I know you had ups and
downs I know you had losses and you had
gains but no matter what your two feet
around the [ __ ] ground and you're
still ready to go 2020 is you you listen
they all can't be here there can't be a
month and the hill can't be a day I
pulled the hamstring I almost ripped it
I was scared I had to cancer Miami and
New York and Boston and all work that I
got back I lost a cat I made a promise
to 12 years ago not not do drugs you
know we all go through things it's how
you go through them pass them move on
and go on to the next level of your life
and that's what I try to do with the
church the church isn't for [ __ ] rich
people or people [ __ ] think they all
of this is for people who uh you know
what we's the [ __ ] I'm the dog and
it's so and we love being the end the
dog I love being the end of dog
I [ __ ] enjoy it cuz you know what I
always win when I'm a [ __ ] on the dog
and you're gonna start taking the same
philosophy it's been a great year you
know I didn't have to meet shooting
these specials I didn't have to [ __ ]
do any contests nothing like that the
goals I wanted to achieve I achieved
which is to be a better comic to be
healthy to be a better father to make
this podcast a little better to be a
better husband and to learn to be a
better friend
tomorrow night's New Year's Eve I don't
know what the [ __ ] you guys are thinking
I know 30 years ago I was thinking about
[ __ ] doing whatever but look a new
people didn't know I didn't get high on
New Year's Eve I got high every night
except New Year's Eve since 1984 when my
friends here got bit off and I couldn't
answer for him because I was too [ __ ]
up 83 so I got high three hundred
sixty some days of the year except new
you completely sobered just not smoking
some joints I always wanted to pay
attention on New Year's you always want
to pay attention on New Year's yeah you
having a good time they think you're
drinking but you got a [ __ ] coke with
a [ __ ] lime and if they think you're
drinking a Cuba Libre you're always
watching that's the way life is you're
always watching let the [ __ ] morons
lose control in public and not know what
the [ __ ] is going on then the next day I
lost my cellphone somebody robbed me
somebody [ __ ] me in the ass while you
passed out that's what happens when you
pass out in the TP I'm saying anyway
yeah what the [ __ ] the reason why do
this wraparound podcast is just to let
you know that it's not over man it's not
over it was just a [ __ ] up here [ __ ]
happens
this time of the year doesn't make it
[ __ ] any worse because this puts
pressure on your BAE push all that [ __ ]
aside cuz you're alive you've got a plan
this year and you got the church you got
us worst case scenario you don't have
you know friends you got merely you
listen to us twice a week we're there
with you you got a question you hit me
up my message on Facebook on Twitter and
we're right there with us this is not a
podcast we're with stars and we're
looking down on you or better than you
when the same brothers you I go along
learning something new every day
somebody told me something I'm gonna
tell you guys something for the next
year and then we'll get the podcast
started up a wise woman last week
watched a one-man show at The Comedy
Store and afterwards she said she
enjoyed it but she comes from a Buddhist
background which is always at the
background because it makes you question
a lot of things and she asked me what I
wanted
I told an array of thing she doesn't
want either write down what do you want
what do you want what do you want seven
times and then write down the answer and
I did it and I came up with some pretty
[ __ ] cool
glances so you don't know what direction
you're taking 20/20 into listen man
nobody needs for you to lose 200 pounds
nobody needs for you to be $20,000
richer
nobody needs for you to [ __ ] do
anything just be a little bit better
than what you were in 2019 that's it
that's all we ask you just be a little
bit better if you [ __ ] whatever
you're gonna do just a little bit better
this year that's it just be human have a
good time and make sure that it's not
listen I know people who got money
coming out of their [ __ ] and they
always got a sourpuss on their face the
other night I uh this is an app called
like ABC Yahoo or some [ __ ] that is for
kids my wife made my daughter write a
letter this sad you know the toys she
won and [ __ ] but I guess this guy's
brother the last podcast this this thing
and she wrote down that all she wanted
to do was be happy and it [ __ ] blew
my mind that a six-year-old can figure
out the answer that took me [ __ ] 40
years to realize because we all get
confused we think that girl's gonna make
us happy that boats gonna make you happy
having that cause and it make you happy
then you get in then what that's the
beautiful thing about life that we never
think about once we get that goal than
what now what the [ __ ] are we gonna do
listen with happiness you can never lose
you know you just go to be happy it's
not about money it's not about [ __ ]
it's not about real estate deals or who
you [ __ ] in the ass cuz when you're
[ __ ] laying in that casket well before
you put get put in that cast and you're
taking your last breath that's not the
[ __ ] you're gonna be thinking about you
didn't be thinking about the good times
that you kids your wife your girlfriend
see your friends you know be a better
friend than 90 and to 20/20 be a better
friend to yourself you know and that's
it
is a [ __ ] simple [ __ ] life only we
make it harder on ourselves with
pressure and listen to people listen to
yourself at the end of the week who pays
your bills you do the [ __ ] you listen to
that [ __ ] jerk before me Lee listen
to yourself
you have natural [ __ ] instincts and
listen man there's the time of the year
also I don't know what people's mind
straight don't let your mind straight go
out be around people this year the
comedy community and you guys cuz you
guys are part of it it's not like 40
years ago when Freddie Prinze shot
himself and you didn't know the [ __ ]
Freddie Freddie Prinze was you know God
rest his soul this year we lost a comic
he was a great friend I know him since
he was a [ __ ] kid and for a couple of
months I was numb for a couple months I
was angry now I'm rapping 2019 up with
him because I learned a lot from that I
learned that we have friends and we have
to use them [ __ ] you and your [ __ ]
psychiatrist a you pay 160 for you give
me 200 a week I'll tell you whatever the
[ __ ] you want to hear you ever think
about that you ever think about that you
[ __ ] idiots you give me some [ __ ]
jerk-off guy lady 180 a week 280 a week
to 2160 140 and they just hate it when
everybody [ __ ] and yeah yeah you feel
good for a while but you know what
what's the problem buying your best
friend a cup of coffee at Denny's and
talking to him and letting him know him
because of this [ __ ] this is why Brody
took his life in the February so this
last podcast of the year I wanted to
bring you hope and let you know that
[ __ ] you got this you got the world
by the ball you got everything to live
for you might think you're painted
against a wall but Joey I'm sleeping on
a tile a [ __ ] I slept on a towel - in
1995 enjoyed it could've been 100 and
I'm saying be happy or what you got
think about your friends and think about
if you get into a bind then you also
well you always have your friends this
is the last time bro
Stephens at this podcast and I want to
end here with this podcast I hope you
enjoyed as much as I do
thank you yes we are here feeling good
relaxed in the moment I'm comfortable
I've been on the show good to see you
guys Lee and Joey always great to bump
into you you know I was thinking about
who I have on this time I said [ __ ]
Brody Stevens I just saw him at the
stolen me get my [ __ ] arm oh yeah it
was yeah I saw you at the store showing
my face see how you doing call me what
time you spots usually I get normally
I'll do Friday or Saturday in the main
room closing it out which is like 12:30
12:45 late and then occasionally I'll
get an earlier spot in the original room
and like at 10:45 or an 11:00 so Adam
the Booker and they they mix it up for
me but I get two to three spots a week
but I make the most of those if I get
those main room spots I can and I go up
at the end that's I get to spread my
wings and do my own thing and that's
what I made my special based on doing
those late-night main room spots or I'm
just kind of letting it go so I still do
those I've kind of you know I've done it
already so I'm looking to do something
more but getting some motivation for you
know but they switch it up but you got
to hustle
got to play Laugh Factory gotta go The
Improv got to do these other shows got
to show your face listen the hustle
never ends
like I said Sebastian Maniscalco sold us
four shows at Madison Square Garden and
I'm telling you every day and all of the
struggle whatever level you're at
comically you know that whatever right
every day you gotta get up and face and
it work and [ __ ] you know whatever it
is that you do to get you know closer to
your goal whatever the [ __ ] it is you
know it's interesting you were talking
about the beginning of the show then you
done with the meds you're done well I
have been for how long
four months how do you feel good I mean
my mood is low I feel like I have to
build up my rewire my brain a little bit
and my body I think that it takes
several months like get it out of your
system and then you get used to being
different but essentially I feel like my
old self but that doesn't that's
some kind of an antidepressant something
to take the edge off since Seattle you
know and I only had I had a year two in
New York when I was not really on
anything but being here in Los Angeles
since 2000 I think yet the pressures
maybe of the internet made me and all
these so many more things happening but
initially I started taking it in Seattle
because I get up there and do comedy and
it would I wouldn't feel right
I wouldn't I felt like oh Brody you're
funny you're funny playing baseball that
when I went up there and did comedy it
was it was rough so I I did take
something to help me have the edge taken
off however I feel like 20 years now
later to say your honor only on a med
because it helps your comedy is kind of
like a weak excuse well listen before by
the way it's I think it's I called it
just to stay safe
I always said it was November 15th but
it was more like the 8th or the 9th when
I gave up cocaine this is 11 years 11
years hopefully this week
congratulations
11 [ __ ] years coke free something
that I never ever ever thought I could
live with that
mm-hmm like something that I thought but
if I got off it I wouldn't be funny that
was my biggest fear of getting off the
cocaine was that I would lose my son to
him yeah so when you said that before
the show started I assured you that that
does not happen you know being I don't
know history was with meds and I didn't
want to put it on the front street but
you put it on the whole street well and
you know what man there's a lot of
people listen to this show better on
meds and maybe it's maybe you inspire
them to maybe go you know what I'm gonna
give myself a chance I'm gonna travel
live my life I'm gonna try to
good control good when he called it
around here good support support system
showing your face being important the
support system around you is the most
important thing you know I took Kate
Quigley to the New York Comedy Festival
mm-hmm and Wednesday night I had all my
friends me to the Chinese restaurant and
we all ate and little by little kept she
kept seeing my friends and she goes I
understand you and now a lot more you
know you've kept in touch with these
people for 40 [ __ ] years mm-hmm and
they support you and you know instead of
me going out and buying a BMW and
getting an assistant I call one of them
every day
and I hear them telling me how they have
to call me back because they're
delivering a package from Federal
Express and they tell me how they have
to drive home at 8:00 but go back to
work at 10:00 because a ship is coming
in and they gotta count stuff so when I
talk to them every day it keeps me
grounded
it says to me [ __ ] they're 55 and I have
a friend who delivers he's 56 that's my
brother need to live his [ __ ]
packages all day for Federal Express I
would give up if you think I did deliver
packages travel Express today you better
[ __ ] shoot yourself either climb up
stairs all day and drop off boxes that's
not gonna happen I would quit the middle
of the day depends on what city any city
I think I wouldn't have I don't have it
in me to deliver packages all day right
now there is no [ __ ] way even if I
was 50 pounds lighter a hundred pounds
lighter there is no way at 55 that I
could be walking up and down stairs I
know there's plenty of men that are
doing it the Amazon guys I'm sure when I
speak to these guys that I grew up with
mm-hmm you know what my boyfriend says
he raps on the weekends to make some
extra 200 hours a week so that's family
so during baseball season he goes up on
stage you know he goes up on stage I'm
sorry he [ __ ] goes to a Little League
field at 8:00 in the morning and he's
dead at 6:00 at night on Saturdays and
Sundays after he delivers fell Express
all [ __ ] week oh the same guy same
guy though
a hundred and seventy five hours for the
day so his family can have an extra 1400
a month and I'm Mike bitching about you
having a gig for four hundred bucks
waiting I'm saying right when I talk to
them it keeps my life in perspective it
keeps me in check I don't want to be
surrounded with people who look at life
for like a value I want it always always
you know
so that's who keeps me grounded that's
my support group those little [ __ ]
friends I call in the morning
and just how I break your balls and
break their balls I know when they're
busy and then when their busiest I call
them then I call them again
these are friends back in back east are
all over although just saying hello
saying hello because it keeps you
[ __ ] ground I talked to Bob Lingus
today all right a listener from the
podcast you know tomorrow I got a call
Bobby Sheeran every day is somebody you
know and these people keep you humble is
it also just socializing keeping those I
love my friends injury yeah I love them
more every time I see him I see him put
ten minutes and it means the world to
him and it means the world to me
mm-hmm when I'm home I go to breakfast
at this one I go to see my mother's
cemetery with that one this one takes me
to get Cuban food this one takes me
through DS this one drives me the chance
so I have a different relationship with
Oliver and I talked to him you know I
have a friend who 55 went to MIT
Massachusetts Institute of New York
where people will [ __ ] geniuses you
know what he does when you live his
bread from midnight to 11:00 in the
morning for 200 halls a [ __ ] move he
makes a thousand bucks a week and
sometimes he works Saturday nights all
night delivering bread in the village
but he's got to work from 6:00 in the
morning with all that traffic he's got
to get over to the Jersey side and I
wouldn't [ __ ] want to do that at all
in my age again so all these guys keep
me grounded
so whatever keeps you ground
from the evil in your mind coming out of
whatever the [ __ ] happens to all of us
that's the most important thing I'm
telling you this is a 55 year old like
I'm an old [ __ ] man and I wish I knew
this when I was 30 yeah that you have to
have three people four people and you
breathe for them and they breathe for
you no questions asked
yeah I have friends I need to I'm from
here it's a little different that's an
excuse though
like my best but not my best from one of
my close friends I still like lives up
near Magic Mountain I should probably
call maybe tomorrow I'll call and
quality I'll call him take him to lunch
I just haven't done it make a deal with
him that you were gonna make sure and
meet him every two weeks for lunch I
need to have the same diner to eat the
same bowl of soup whether it's a Jewish
what if I have an audition good for [ __ ]
that's the problem that's the problem
that we forget who we are because we
have the audition I had a commitment
with you every Sunday had eleven o'clock
you have to make that commitment
tomorrow you know pisses me off tomorrow
and today was my heavy day so today I
lifted her what the kickboxing tomorrow
I'm gonna wake up on my back was in a
field if I miss jujitsu I feel guilty
because I had a date with jujitsu when I
get a [ __ ] call for an audition on
the Tuesday at 1:00
I get pissed cuz I gotta miss jujitsu
right when I got a call for a [ __ ]
meeting to meet somebody at 2:00 o'clock
and the Hollywood that means I can't go
to judge it so I gonna do the
conditioning and huh I get [ __ ]
pissed
you know I don't want nothing to
interfere whatever keeps me grounded and
I wish that I had known this when I
first moved to LA and I didn't have a
grounding I had people like Ralphie May
and yourself and Josh wolves and
whatever but nobody protected me from
myself
which nobody could ever do nobody could
protect you from being you it takes you
to protect yourself I know right
how hard is that it's hard it's hard you
know
that's why you need you know having
family having a wife or a husband or a
dog or something or it's you gotta have
you have to bill if you don't have that
you got to build up your support system
you got a it just takes effort it takes
effort and you want it and be a good
person I think but also getting out of
the house it's just with the internet
these days
social media it does affect people well
how long have you lived alone Brody
probably now for great question Lee
probably now for six years because like
I lived alone for eight years something
like that and even this weekend I was
like something's happened that I wore in
the way I mean I was just getting into
my head mm-hmm and I didn't I talked to
a few people but I don't
most of the damn by myself and even just
as terrible as I sounded I was just
driving and I just was thinking about
what's going on with the fire sounds
like you know what this is that really
doesn't matter like what I'm going
through is it in the grand scheme of
things I'm Jude I'm making a worse in my
head so I think it's hard sometimes as a
person who lives alone to like get out
of their head well yeah I mean that's
why I well one I go for walks actually
getting out and then I do that periscope
I do talk I mean I'm not hearing their
voices but I am doing these check-ins I
am connecting with my community there is
something true to having a your audience
your fans they do mean something so I do
lean on them some sometimes more than
others so you know having a roommate I
had a roommate back my old my last
apartment and he was a really good
roommate they're hard to come by but I
think yes being social and when you are
living alone and you're it's it could be
you're gonna like make it happen but
when you if you like I said look you
called me today Joey I didn't know you
know this was not like something that
was booked it was energy I feel like you
got to be in it to win it that's half
the battle so and not feeling sorry for
yourself but I think having a roommate
you think that would be better like no I
because trust me I haven't had a
roommate since college and that's oh
really yeah it's it but IIIi have
sacrificed financially for it I could
have saved a lot of money by getting a
roommate or even if I was spending the
same amount of money getting a bigger
place but I live with someone for a year
and even he would say when I did it it's
like I'm a bear I'm a very much
introverted person yeah
and it takes a special kind I can't live
with that many people okay I like my
space I like I like to go somewhere and
have no one like to unplug I want
something that's been kind of a struggle
for me that I have to work on is hanging
out after comedy sets I don't feel
comfortable really hanging out after
yeah after the show yeah so yeah and
what talking to the other comedians
talking to the fans well the audience
member sniff I mean the people you know
the people who come it's a little bit
different it's quicker conversations I
can ask them about can talk be like hey
what are you doing
listen that but and I have some friends
I do open mics with now right but uh I
don't unless it's a few people like two
or three people I could hang around for
an hour if it's seven or eight people
I'll hang around for like 20 minutes so
you just want to get out of there yeah I
just want to go home and you feel like
that's not good yeah I think I need to
be a little bit more so I mean I'm more
social already but I think it would be
beneficial if I was you know hanging out
and to know people and like a more
personal basis I mean that's why the
comedy store so popular yeah I'm gonna
hang out you hang out there right you
come by there a little bit yeah and I'm
gonna I've been I just have to force
myself to to stay and and do I I haven't
ever done it like twice in the past week
but at one of the times I had a show so
it didn't really I didn't really count
it as just hanging out but you set up
you go like on a you know whatever night
what's your I have to start doing that
more I'm avoiding it yeah because
everybody's hanging out there they're
all similar same likes and you know
you're at the Comedy Store right and
then you're gonna meet other comedians
you're gonna meet fans you're gonna be
around people all that stuff i mean
that's why i go i I go I know I have a
place I do the same thing yeah I do the
same thing I for
myself to go to store but let's back
this conversation up because these are
some interesting [ __ ] things that are
happening okay just now Lee and I when
we first started doing the podcast we
started at my apartment had an extra
bedroom and then and this is not I'm not
hating only people we knows what I'm
about to tell you people and then we got
an apartment but it was a two-bedroom
and we do the bed the podcast out of his
apartment
mhm and I lovely Leah's come alone my
homely those my family Lika come to my
home whenever he wants he knows that
yeah I know from doing the podcast that
year and Lee's apartment and how he
acted that I have never been back to one
of these apartment not because he's a
bad person he's always hosted me he
always had diet cokes for me his
apartment was clean okay okay I just
know we I know from me being Who I am
that we as people who want you at their
house there's people who love open up
the door
gonna come in come in sit down take your
shoes off put your feet on the table get
there's people were Naturals at that
yeah there's people were [ __ ] Naturals
at that they want to entertain I wish I
could be one of those people okay
so on just that relationship of me going
to Lee's home in the mornings you knew
his podcast and at one time there was a
girl sleeping on his couch oh I could
see that the effect of when that girl
moved out on Lee and I tried to tell him
not because I'm a hater before Lee told
me he was on her let his girlfriend move
in a goalie from a standpoint of a
[ __ ] old man that reads people and
there's a loner remember guys I was
alone it you put me in my room by myself
as a kid I was alone I was a lonely
child long as I got a [ __ ] record
player and the TV but something happened
to me in 1987 that 1986 something
interesting happened to me
and I'll admit this on the air right now
and it's called something but it
affected me in a different way it's
called cabin fever
okay the same thing that happened to ya
so the guy in the shining well now yeah
okay so what happened is in Aspen the
spring of 86 my girlfriend who became my
wife said it's the offseason everybody
loses their job so instead of sitting
all the restaurants closed right now
everything closes I mean it goes from
being aa heavy-duty [ __ ] people
jumping off cliffs with bikinis on 2
April 15 leave nothing like nothing like
from traffic just six cars and the only
thing that stays open as a supermarket
at least is this I wasn't lady 600 I
would stay open Lee was a supermarket
for limited hours cuz all that was left
was the residents at that time people
who worked at the slowly instead of
there being nine bars now there was a
hotel with one bar open and that's the
way it was till mid June then the
bicycle races came and hot air balloons
came and then it became people come back
up yeah but this is six weeks family
that I had to work three hours a day
some days just to open up the video
store and I could look you guys in the
face and tell you that there were days I
wouldn't even open the door the door
this is no drugs this is me smoking pop
pop in video after video in the movies
video after video not watching movies
yeah pissing and [ __ ] in between
eating something in between making a
shade yeah I did that you could do that
back then I did that for six weeks
well it's like a film festival eight had
been really weird because before that I
lived in New York and I had a hostel
that was our house every day I ate a
block stealing selling drugs yep
stealing [ __ ] tampons and sell them
on the New York side to bodegas up on
the Washington Heights
I was just a friend you know and those
six weeks affected me I started to twist
a little bit
I started to get bad thoughts not
suicidal you know coming back and
murdering my stepdad and just [ __ ]
dumb stuff so from those six weeks I
learned one thing from my personal
mental house it was always good for me
get up cup of coffee you know go to your
balcony it u-joint twice
you have to Chad together yep write out
a plan for your day what you want to
accomplish for the day like in written
form in the paragraph so I feel great I
got eight hours to sleep ba-ba-ba-ba and
take a shower and get out of the house
even if you have nowhere to go and make
your bed actually it's so healthy for
you but if you look at the questionnaire
for depression its it starts with that
being alone enough getting your hands
forced mm-hmm you know I'm not crying
but you're getting your hands for us to
do something a lot of people don't like
the hand force when you say hand forced
if you get a roommate you can't do what
you usually do act like a [ __ ] gavone
and just sit on the couch all day and
watch videos okay now you have a
roommate Lea made the point that he's
been living alone but if he had a
roommate maybe he get out of the house
more I believe in getting out of the
[ __ ] house I think it's I think the
Sun has amazing powers I think the air
has amazing power you know it's some
days I'm feeling ho-hum I know is that
what it is I haven't jumped in the
shower it it's it's proven walking is
beneficial for you for your brain for
your Bob for everything so there's no
the only thing somebody would say about
walking you should be doing more you
should be then turn it into a hike the
bottom line is walking helps anybody you
know if it's helping you and especially
as a performer you know mental meant it
just mentally I go out and I walk and a
lot of the creative ideas come from when
people walk I do my periscope so I'm
walking I check in with people and then
luckily we're here in Southern
California we and
we have that sunlight so I do you know
at least I'm doing that I always say
like I'm not a couch potato I'm checking
and even if I'm doing another periscope
and I'm playing drums I'm sitting on a
Swiss ball I'm exercising so I'm trying
to at least you know show people like
being active and if I don't do a
periscope or you know I don't do an
Instagram video people are gonna go hey
Brody what's up so they kind of it's it
still doesn't beat having an actual
physical person with you it's a little
bit of an a I think when you when you
have relationships with your audience
members that you actually don't even
hear their voices so you do need that
human interaction and part of it is
having guests on a podcast I've been to
I got to the point where I wasn't even
booking guests on podcast there's just
me and you know the mic and the camera
it's like I need to be around people so
I've made a concerted effort I think the
last couple months or so is like be
social put the put the effort out and
yet get out of your head just so and I
see results I got at least try I mean
listen you and I like it
you have to be in your head to be
self-conscious but I don't want you to
be this self-conscious that you destroy
yourself from 79 to 85 walking was my
psychiatrist walking with and without an
iPod pad on whatever would call those a
Walkman Walkman discman well I walked
miles and that was my psychiatry mmm-hmm
we just walked walk walk
get your steps up walk walk I didn't do
it for health reasons
it was the psychiatry had I had a
breakdown what had just happened in my
life and how is gonna make my future
better
mm-hmm and it would be smoking a joint
and walking from Cliffside Park the
[ __ ] Englewood and back six miles or
something a retardation just wasting
time
mm-hmm I was free what's that called
procrastinating yeah that's what I was
also breaking it down what had just
happened and I was breaking down my next
attack and I finally had the balls and
I mean I launched an 85 that was my
attack but that was a year of walking so
you were walking before you were doing
stand-up let stand up wasn't even in my
future okay
Prison was in my future at that gotcha
and I was a walker walking away like if
I lived here I would walk towards
[ __ ] you know Sunland mm-hmm every
day you know on a slant with a knife I
would force myself to walk by myself no
cell phone in your pocket no calls and
break down what had just happened in my
life the death of my mother how I was
gonna survive was I gonna go to
vocational school was I gonna go to
college was I gonna get my GED housing
you know it was just a constant walking
was my psychiatrist you know today I got
up this morning early there was no
school today so me and my wife had a
shared duties so I got up this morning
on out with her early watch television
and then at 9:00 I went and went to my
Muay Thai little conditioning class
mm-hmm what happened before I walked in
I got to the quarter-mile I just did
that about my car before minutes and I
just soaked in the Sun mm-hmm
by Manny and naturally I said to myself
just being outside is helping me mm-hmm
you know I always tell people you could
take private lessons or you could be in
a class setting
I'm much rather be in a class setting so
I have relationships with different
people in that class because I'm the
type of guy that I can get up at 8:00
kotemari tea and sit there riding to one
and then go home go to your office and
I'm social media for an hour return
emails mmm and then talk to my wife talk
to my kid and I could stay home mm-hmm
and I could do that for three or four
nights in a row
and that sucks death that makes me go
crazy it's a lot of reason why I call it
four spots at the comedy stores to force
me to get off my ass and go down it
because you can't cancel
no so you have to go down there
well I'm driving back from the Comedy
Store I feel so satisfied at the end of
the day but I accomplished my mission
for the day even if you have a bad set
even if every bad so it's not about bad
sets organically it's about the same two
things you guys are talking about human
contact yeah yeah I mean that's that's
one thing you need it we're human beings
I'm talking about as soon as you wake up
I want you to give yourself an hour for
you I want you to take that hour I
always think when I get up in the
morning I thank the Lord that he gave me
another day and I thank the Lord that I
didn't grow up I'm not growing up in the
house we're at 6:30 in the morning
a bomb gets dropped in your house leaves
getting shaved I gotta wait for him we
can't use the bathroom because Brody
took a [ __ ] it smells like [ __ ] ten
people died there yeah yeah washing
machine broke so the [ __ ] your shirts
not ready no now you gotta iron it by
hand everybody's getting up in a bad
mood and now you gotta get on a train a
bad mood nobody's late to work I [ __ ]
hated that [ __ ] we don't want that did
not fly my world I know I needed to get
up I need a little break in the morning
I put music on I get coffee I sit there
with a notebook that's wide open
I put Tuesday November 13th on it unless
say it's a beautiful day for me to be
alive and from there I just wet and I
don't stop to the end of the page so
your journal
that's not journal in the morning to get
the waste out today I'm gonna do this
justice this I [ __ ] don't want to do
it because the 405 is gonna have traffic
on it and when I talked myself I had
everything I could talk myself out of so
it's all over
after that page my day is decided you
know what I was gonna do what's his name
his podcast I'm not driving to Marina
del Rey I'm texting him at nine o'clock
and tell them you're in no danger you
know that's when I decided that how I
feel if I wake up on my back hurt so I
can't move and I'm not gonna go to Jeju
to a 12 let's make alternate plans who's
got a podcast you got a podcast yet when
do you do it once well let's do it
tomorrow at 12 that's
how I work because I don't want to skip
I don't know what I'm be available but
it's about also you know scheduling
stuff scheduling stuff and always
keeping yourself busy this business what
we do let me tell you something and I'm
not gonna do this that none of you
people anymore because I know sometimes
when comedians can bond here [ __ ] in
today's world it gets crazy if you get
caught up in today's world between the
internet oh yeah the media
oh yeah and what's going on you were
gonna go crazy
yep I'm not gonna mention no names cuz
I'm not here embarrass somebody but I
think we have discussed that we've seen
a couple people lose their minds within
the last two or three years oh yeah on
the internet on the internet in public
we've seen we've heard of people losing
their minds there's too much information
getting poured into the human mind right
now yep so right now you have to learn
how to control that too you have to
learn how to control that dough and
decide on what level how much of this
are you gonna take in you know what I'm
listening to eleven podcast a week
that's 33 hours I got to chop it down to
five you do you know what I'm watching
too much [ __ ] football
I gotta chop it down or just Sundays no
more Thursday again I'm gonna take a
shift to [ __ ] chill this isn't as I
cook you know I'm saying like I'm gonna
take an extra shift you have to control
what gets put into your mind right now
because of what's going on in the world
what ABC news just greeting you and when
the internet is feeding you it really
really is overwhelming for the mind yeah
I well I don't look at you know the ABC
news really I'll glance at those guys
but I listen to all right I listen to
KFI local radio here in LA but I go on
the internet for my news and it's it's I
mean it's a battle out there to be
honest with you how it is and I wake up
every morning and a lot of times to be
honest I'm up
in the morning I'm looking at that
internet I'm looking at that Twitter and
I'm look I'm trying to find things and I
I do my sets at the economy store I come
home I go straight to Twitter and I'm
not on there like get in fights of
people I'm just researching stuff I'm
researching stuff and I feel like I'm
ahead of the head of the game on on
what's happening and I feel like the
last few years with with the politics
the way they are it has kind of taken
taken pulled me into an area at least my
energy not necessarily I'm not getting
into fights on the internet I'm not that
guy but it does get your blood boiling a
little bit but I do avoid it but I also
I'm digging in oh I want I want I want
honestly I want everybody to be happy I
want to do whatever it takes to get it
back to where we're happy and working
together and that's what I'm pulled in
there too and it takes takes your time
and I feel like I'm not a part of that
mob mentality I'm a little I'm a little
different on blue-collar I'm from the
valley grew up you know and it bothers
me what I don't like seeing comedian
friends of mine angry on Twitter so I do
not I try not to not try to block it and
not see it but it's a bummer for me and
so that can get to you I feel it's a
tough time to be a human being right now
it's I feel mentally if you get sucked
in it's a tough time to be a human being
right now you have to know your yang and
your yang and your borders you know you
have to make time for yourself you have
to take care of yourself yes you have to
you know you're talking to a guy that
lived in his head for years and it got
me nowhere it got me nowhere so I
expressed what was in my head that's
where I started getting places you know
we overthink things and in the process
of thinking we think ourselves out of
the game right learn to think about you
get the idea
you got a piece of paper you write it
out and you go to work
so you weren't you weren't journaling
during that years you're in your head
not even thinking about it
there was no journaling there was
nothing there was no journaling in my
life till 1994
nice to meet inner knowing my calmly
stuff that's nice and then I went to
Seattle and there was a skinny woman
that was a comic that wasn't that funny
old or married and one day she turned me
on to a book called the writer's way or
something and she told me I could borrow
it for a few days and I read it and then
there already I was doing it in there a
recommended excuse me that when you wake
up in the morning you should get a fresh
piece of paper and express your thoughts
for the day I was like I'm on to
something if they're telling you this at
this time this was the hot book you know
the book right the riders way or there
was a gene beret no no no it wasn't it
wasn't family right okay
riding and house-elf out yeah journaling
this is I learned that in college
Arizona State I never knew about
journaling though comedy having like a
coked-up I would journal at night you
know like telling myself this is the
last time I'm gonna do it I have to stop
this life even though I get set tonight
I'm making good moves in my life am I
still writing doing coke I think
journaling is the best thing in the
world for you I think journaling is the
best psychiatry I think every Friday
every Saturday morning I wake up and I
had we thought I read but I read for the
week I read what I wrote mmm Monday on
number one everything that I write in
that journal in the mornings gets done
plus I have another notebook that has my
schedule plus you have a calendar that
has my schedule and
you know I have three things to know my
schedule one is my day step-by-step nine
o'clock eleven o'clock twelve thirty
four o'clock five during the eight
o'clock podcast ten o'clock spot at the
Comedy Store and then there's the
journal part of it right it's just a
yellow notebook and every day I wake up
when I write backwards to front so I
start all back and I write to the front
that'll start in the front I started the
back and why it's the front just
superstitious I don't want to write like
everybody else I'm starting to back of
it right to the front and it opens up
with Monday November 13th first line is
always just a beautiful day to be alive
that's the first thought that she's
coming to you add I don't give a [ __ ] if
you're in a ditch and there's a rock on
top as long as you're breathing if you
say that to yourself your day is gonna
be completely [ __ ] different it's
been proven it's been proven people pray
the limits go up you're not supposed to
pray they say though these are some
prayers you're not supposed to pray but
saying that to yourself it's a beautiful
day to be able God why are you pissing
why are you pissing all that piss is
coming out here
and your knee hurts your neck is stiff I
mean [ __ ] and that blister under your
tongue from eating [ __ ] and ass can
happen and the chief doctor Midea it
still doesn't matter why you're peeing
if you say to yourself it's a beautiful
day to be alive whatever [ __ ] comes into
your mind on top of that it's not gonna
matter I gotta go to court today I'm
broke I'm hungry a lot of money a parent
and you say that to yourself first
it's a beautiful that every journal of
mine starts like that right Thursday
November 16th it's a [ __ ] beautiful
[ __ ] day to be alive today I gotta do
this I gotta do this I gotta go see this
[ __ ] scumbag I gotta go deal with
this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
and whatever I got to pick the baby up
before but hey you know what twenty
years ago I was [ __ ] trying to stab
somebody look where I am today at least
I am living and breathing I'm healthy I
you know it's just that part of it yeah
well that's why I like working on a TV
show every day or working with maybe
with the baseball team you bring that
energy and yes we're here push they
people like that they like that energy
bringing it lifting people up positive
self-talk you have to do it because it
does work I know it sounds silly but it
does work to put that you're putting
that energy out it really is an energy
of your putting it out it does I'm not
saying it comes back to you but you do
put it out and people like being around
it that's the thing people like being
around that that's you know it's a moat
it's like a coach it's motivational
upbeat it can be done and you can kind
of train yourself I would think at least
to believe that it works you know it's
not easy to do
but if you believe it you know what's
there and that's what I and I learned
that from I learned in at Arizona State
about the power of the mind being
positive and visualizing because I saw
it affect my pitching I saw it affect my
schoolwork I saw it affect my confidence
I got everything out of out of baseball
Arizona State that I wanted and it's the
and I and I apply those rules today like
at the Comedy Store playing Division one
sports was a big thing and I happen to
go to Arizona State where we have a lot
of players in the major leagues
so I and we had access to professional
baseball coaches there and that's where
I learned the visualization and then I
see it around when I hung out with the
baseball teams the Yankees the Dodgers
and the Cubs and there's something to it
so I I'm not trying to figure it out
still but I know it's something there
you know and I can apply it to myself a
lot of the time you know it's easy to
say but and you know that's why I
wouldn't mind being around in baseball
CNN did the thing that bothered the [ __ ]
out of me it bothered the [ __ ] out of me
because I felt that a game excuse it had
a they had docu-series called the dark
side economy the dark side of comedy oh
one thing comics and they discussed
Robin Williams and the suicides
yeah the drugs and a Kennison than all
this [ __ ] and I agree with a lot of part
of it but I recently dealt with some
[ __ ] I don't know what it was I don't
know what it was it started like in
March and it went on until maybe the
second week of July after I shot the
Netflix special
it wasn't pressure it was just just
doubt dis dis this form of depression
that came over me you know it affected
my stomach and it was just really weird
that I found out from reading the old
journals mmm month ago three weeks ago I
go let me go back and see what I was
writing in March yeah and one thing
about depression is depression is a
[ __ ] if you let him in yeah okay
so how do you let depression in from
getting into your mind and not getting
sunlight not having contact and I know
all about it because like I'm telling
you guys I [ __ ] hate driving I
[ __ ] hate it but those weeks on in
town all week I thought have to go on
the road sometimes I schedule something
for Thursday mm-hmm that's out of my
character and the whole week I'd read it
but while I'm driving in the 405 didn't
bumper-to-bumper traffic angle thank God
I got out of the valley I thank God I
thank [ __ ] god like enough is enough
that's the other reason why I called
four spots at the store makes me get out
of the valley yeah we go over the hill
every night every night you know I know
I can't do with every night but guys I
suffer from the same thing you guys
suffer from I learned about it 20 years
ago cuz I get 30 years ago I could stay
in they could put me on a [ __ ] island
that's my dream guys that's my dream
that my daughter grows up my wife tells
me she's gonna go and live in [ __ ]
and I [ __ ] go you know what there's
an island for 60 G's [ __ ] the Navy
drop bombs they're 20 years ago and this
[ __ ] nuclear reactive I've got a
little chip of the aisle and get some
chicken cutlets you can imagine I'm the
type of guy that could be a normal day
with music marijuana I swear to God
drums I liked rose waits wing a punching
bag TV of internet internet where you
will you podcast and para no no no no no
gun lock myself in oh I could be one of
those guys that I could stay in I can
eat the same [ __ ] every day
I could either mortar down or salami and
American cheese sandwich every day Oh
protein shakes I had to live on one
every day I'm a [ __ ] creature of
habit so hum the times I scare myself
with that [ __ ] I scare myself with that
[ __ ] that's why I forced myself to get
the [ __ ] out I forced I went through
that cocaine morning [ __ ] well you don't
want to leave the house because the cops
are watching you and all that yeah no no
no no no ever since I stopped that I
forced myself out because even I always
knew that that was the dark side of town
the dark side of comedy is getting into
your mind but it's not the dark side
economy it's a dark side of life yeah
it's a duck son life it's not the dark
side of comedy if you let depression end
so as soon as you start feeling that
[ __ ] or that stuff that that gets you
all while boom that's it you're out of
it but well smoke a joint go for a walk
go go go for a walk go gig call talk
hopefully go talk this online I'm not
talking about something that you pay I'm
talking about go talk to a friend a
friend somebody else Starbucks was there
with a will sees you just forcing
yourself you know I do a stupid joke
about the universe it's very true you
get back will you put in yes you know
you're lonely go to a kickboxing class
there's a people in there you're gonna
drive one of those people that one hour
of you talking to those other people
don't get Yanni and your phones in the
car
your mother's fine your first thing I
worry about is your mother can your
father everything else is [ __ ] what
a brother's ain't gonna call you while
you're in kickboxing class nobody's
gonna call you while you're in
kickboxing class this times I got like a
Jitsu class come levar when I get the
collar be a mess now you ain't got
nothing nobody called you nobody's gonna
call you but just a thought I'm getting
away from the phone yeah just that other
perfect just forcing you away from that
phone one hour it's in the car and if it
melts let it [ __ ] melt I got
insurance I'm gonna do but just getting
away from all I said all this is lately
is we have too much [ __ ] information
why do you think comedy so big right now
why do you think I'm telling you to do a
show in the daytime because man I
wouldn't [ __ ] say this if I didn't
believe in it five years ago I would not
believe this statement okay people need
family they do work we're telling the
truth people love it that that's they
love it that's why
especially the we're on the front lines
at the Comedy Store
we're here in Hollywood and I feel like
if you have hairy slopes
you're [ __ ] just cat watching you
interact with the donut Korean let's say
you did let's say you went to the same
cold water a river side next to the dry
cleaners there's a problem of God you
place this is Chinese doughnut in there
there's a doughnut in yeah on the corner
I know there's a Mexican joint there
yeah it's a high frozen ice shaved ice
shaved ice those people real Korean in
there well then then when they're
together bagel I asked him for like a
[ __ ] and this guy tried to sell me
like no picture that Korean is ruthless
he's like one of them come pumpkin bang
go listen oh you don't put along some
pumpkin bagel I'm from here yeah I'm
saying you don't give a [ __ ] I have I
have no onion but I have their blueberry
but a lot of some blueberry good for you
oh good for you you going in torch that
every day on candle for three minutes
that's a series for four minutes a day
people are paying down
to see you the one that had noted place
and asked that more thought he only said
him in balance
you just run from there but I I know
every day you open up and say please
don't ask that guy every day for like I
would if I knew that that China guy
would get pissed off I walk in there
every day knowing that he didn't haven't
done it and then I send them people in
this like that's the best for you
torture people to keep your brain job
like you torture people just like
entertain like a like you're like just
doing it to like socialize with a few
patreon oh my god
you have no idea how much fun you can
have on the infinite today if I had the
time and the energy I just go into
yom-yom every day yom-yom minute just
going in torture them how many calories
in the doughnut and then like looking at
you like you know another language you
going everyday and he asked you
different color you never get a doughnut
but that but that's the thing now today
whom free doughnuts you have almost like
no reason to be not saying no reason to
be depressed but there's so many outlets
before like what if you're staying home
you were sick what do you have like ten
channels on TV and that's it now you've
got so many yes there's a lot of
drawbacks to the internet and social
media and all that but it is there are a
lot of positives associated with it you
just got to be able to maintain it and
also know that it can be used for some
good well I mean times have changed
I don't know but you guys are hotels
every week pretty much whenever I go to
a hotel I used to love I would have TV
on our watch SportsCenter of this than
that I don't I know I'll be in a hotel
room for a weekend and not turn it on
see I want myself to leave the hotel
room every two hours smoke a joint
that's why I bring extra weed I smoke a
joint I get the gym I forced myself to
leave the room every two hours and I
forced myself to leave the hotel room
for a patch I forced myself on Saturday
to go to lunch with somebody you know
somebody from the club the club owner I
do little things but just enough to
scratch that itch
I can't go to a baseball game
for three innings 70 days you know I do
enough just to scratch that edge so when
you go to town you'll schedule
appointments with people to keep that
human contact going right I'll schedule
a Muay Thai class well know what the
jersey is we got to get private
jiu-jitsu class in Jersey on Friday you
know I went to the gym on Saturday I
forced my I have to force myself because
if not I will sit in front of that iPad
a little watch sick I you know what I
love about the road what do you long
don't want to go on the road to watch
your iPad no it's not to make money I
love to meet different people make
people laugh I go on the road for Friday
night that's your night that's my name
to go do a great show make them laugh
and meet people memories put out good
energy and no I don't have to do [ __ ] on
Saturday morning you like that that
means I could go back and anything goes
on Friday night mm-hmm okay that means
that if you come up to me and give me
two vicodins I might go back to the room
and pop one put on a pot of coffee get a
notebook out and I watch I swear to God
I got no reason to lie another yes i
watch five episodes of sons of anarchy
Jesus Lee how much do I yell at you for
watching TV a lot yeah on Friday nights
when I'm on the road yeah that's me
that's my gift for leaving my family I
got a table I put my feet up with a
pillow to elevate above my heart because
I just fell on stage for two hours yeah
and I just sit there I gotta bring a
vapor pen I bring nicotine gum mm-hmm
sometimes I bring a bag of Doritos lure
up to my room and sometimes I eat it
sometimes I leave it for the maid I get
coffee throwing and coffee after the
show in my room it's my night to do
whatever the [ __ ] I want on Friday night
after a show and I can't wait to get
back to the hotel
sometimes somebody will give me a pill
or something and I'll hold it for when I
go on the road to drop it that night
while I'm in the hotel I'm frying I like
if you give me two vicodins a hold on to
them and I know that when I go to
Portland Friday night after the show
I'll pop to Vytas isn't going I'll
scratch and I'll watch narcos and I
watch four episodes and narcos and not
blink an eye I could do that that to me
is fun because I know I'm gonna get up
at 8:00 I'm still gonna go for breakfast
and I'm gonna go back to my room and
sleep another three hours I'm still
gonna get up early and still gonna go to
breakfast I still forced myself out to
breakfast walk down stairs it sucks but
I make myself do it just even talk to
the waitress pumping hey that was a good
show us and I thank you then you go back
to your room sleep for three hours get
up I'll watch an art goes right I'm out
I'm back but I thought that two more I
was writing out one and a half I was
writing out out go roll the joint
smoked a half or join hide it behind the
building come back so I do yeah I don't
walk into the hotel with enjo in my hand
and the whole room smells I get two
things I put a rock on top of it when I
come back two hours later and I guess I
stick the rock off it and they smoke the
other half and how do you stay
disciplined on all of this is is just
what makes you happy makes the shows
better you visit or makes the show
better this is what makes me better this
is we are creatures of whatever you know
we and we have to force ourselves and I
didn't notice you have to force yourself
sometimes too how do you comfort zone
comfort zone is a big [ __ ] word man
mm-hmm
that's an ugly [ __ ] word and once you
feel yourself in that comfort zone get
in the [ __ ] car get out of the
comfort zone yeah
yeah get out it was pretty funny
leaving the show this week and it was
you know I fell in love with Brody
I don't know nineteen years ago on a bar
in Gig Harbor I'll never forget and I'll
never forget what he said how he said in
the poise that he said it that's when
Lou Brody was real you know he was on
stage yeah and I'm told this on there ya
know he's the yelling screaming and in
the middle of it he turned around and
there was a bunch of photographs on the
wall he's up on stage yelling and
screaming or they just stopped because I
come there's no Jews upon the walls make
somebody come here that better be Jews
on the wall I'll never come to gang
harbor again I'm in the back with Josh
wolf
he's a kid I'm Howlin I found lovely you
know gig harbor yep that gig was a gig
of death yep Ross of Arizona's bridge it
was home it wasn't no [ __ ] evening at
the pop see them saying no so yeah and I
believe goes down the heady Bravo's 15th
reunion they told this poor bastard on
stage while the UFC's on he's up there
in the Korean zombie gets knocked out
and poor leaves up there with his a
material come on in front of the screen
thinking these aren't Conan they
somebody came up to me and I'm by the
way we're at the 10th planet party we
feel so bad fully he want this I swear
to God I swear to God they were like
tough spot
who the [ __ ] did that there I survived I
did my stuff but it's weird yeah is he
called his friend Eric gay Eric my buddy
Eric Rosen
and Eric bought him a beer because he
was so depressed he you know he felt it
and I explained them last night I go
I've been doing comedy 27 years I open
throw can help for dice I throw all
these gigs and I gotta tell you
something half of your career is don't
rooms you know when you get there and
listen and the Seattle Mariners are in
the playoffs and it's the seventh inning
and it's just a those tougher audience
and you get like boom boom we wanna
watch the game put the game on
well they gotta do comedy and also the
owner gets into an argument they do
comedy here we don't give a [ __ ] about
comedy right put the game on but take
the volume off oh yeah that's it you
know and you're up there on stage
dynasty
that thinking about career choices you
just want to zip recruiter you looked
you know it's it's [ __ ] harm but then
you do a guest spot open at the
underground and see I don't know them
and that makes all that go away because
your strength isn't from going on
staging to see how underground your
strength from going onstage at those
places the he'll get where they're not a
youth hostels yeah well they're not
there to see to be out the power I'm
gonna get a grand gig harbor sucked and
the chubby Jew wants to go on stage and
do comedy well I got this chick buddy
here yeah I got this chick right here
and and some [ __ ] Jew and a [ __ ]
fat Cuban I gotta go up on stage and try
to be funny people hate that [ __ ]
especially it's unexpected it's weird
because I did I did an unexpected one
earlier that week and I went fine I went
pretty well but then I was I did a show
on Thursday at a burger place but it
went okay would but I was talking to
Jerry Rocha and the guy who runs the
show Justin and he was saying oh bear
burger yeah yeah that's a good room it
was fun I've done it twice but they were
saying that they they did a show with
someone who didn't get booed off stage
got knocked off stage and that's pretty
much I got I had a section of the crowd
listening but what they were saying was
it's not that they didn't like them and
so they were just indifferent they were
like the people that crabbers is talking
amongst themselves so loud that the
comment got offstage well in those rooms
just way you learn presence yep
you learn how to fake the funk you learn
how to it's a weird thing to describe
you have to learn how to overtake them
without overtaking because if not you're
gonna borrow throw that you [ __ ] that
that's the reality of it yeah you know
I've seen it and I've heard about it you
know I was at a bar one night where they
were flipping bottle caps at the cops is
my thing you know when you and they got
like a red light on them and you can see
the bottle caps wizards and you can see
the comics like ducking from time that
that still happens no I don't you know I
we I haven't heard about it yeah but
there's God
a [ __ ] country bar somewhere or some
[ __ ] crazy bar some young man that
they still you know throwing things at
people you know when we used to do
Moscow Idaho mm-hmm they would send you
25 shots oh yeah after Keela with with
Tabasco sauce Jesus and you had to do
him oh my god they boo you off the stage
holy [ __ ] and you had a half hour and
that the trick was to kill the feature
and to just make the headline and going
to [ __ ] convulsions that's what they
wanted to dance if they wanted to do it
didn't care about the column the first
time you did a shot of tequila what you
weren't on stage five minutes and then
we're giving you a prayer what what's
called prairie fire door a prairie dog
oh my god they would give you see what
it's called tequila and Tabasco delete
Bellingham no no no Moscow oh yeah close
to a local state yeah Washington Idaho
State University yeah the Vandals
because that's the college that drew
blood so winter prairie fire
for every denial let me tell you
something we think about going on stage
okay I'm like you're opening up for some
addition coz over again at this hotel
and it's all college students 200
college students and you go up on stage
and five minutes into you're right the
waitress comes up to you with a shot you
can't tell how do I know I'm not going a
tequila - as soon as you turn down that
shot it's gonna be a 25 and you can't
get off because you won't get paid you
can't get off cuz you won't get paid so
you take no time the club holders gonna
say to you you only did 21 but I gotta
call the Booker and see what to do oh my
so now you look like a [ __ ] jerk-off
so you have to either drink that shot
and take what comes with because they're
not gonna pay that and your material is
not worthy of anything just take the
shots and talk about grande drunk with
them that's what your 30 minutes is
gonna be about that's what these Road
gigs are like Moscow I the whole time
[ __ ] times and after the third time I
got it sorry Charlie it's not gonna be
any different first two times I just
bombed I drank them the third time I
puked in the sink I never forget that I
puked in the st. Jesus and then every
time after I just brought cocaine with
me and I didn't get sick anymore
but one time I had the bed spins yeah I
don't want that it's [ __ ] bad and
there were 10,000 Walland in Missoula
Montana was like that there was 20 bars
that dog as soon as you went onstage
give him a shot of whiskey
get another shot of whiskey and you
better drink them god forbid you had to
drive to another gig there's no there's
no jury you don't even think about it
it's over you're sleeping in the car and
you're gonna [ __ ] drive 90 the whole
morning well I was thinking about this
when you when you told me that Brody was
coming in I was like you Joey and Brody
are probably two of the most comfortable
people on stay like I feel like you feel
comfortable on stage
Camby yeah and like it blows my mind
that you Brody will go on at the in the
main room and do like the drumming like
it's I just did the main room for my
first time everyone I got there like an
hour early right and was petrified like
how we have you always been that
comfortable in order to take years to
get that sort of like that's a level of
comfort that most people don't have um
it took a long time but you know once I
went for it once you like take that milk
and you pour it into that cereal you
like gotta go for it so I gotta be off
you had it than that I'm a thing like
that you did that you had that already
so yeah I already had that I don't give
a [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] my pants I don't
give a [ __ ] attitude I could tell you
were [ __ ] in pants but you were
taking chances taking chances
probably we were young comics yeah in 95
I've been doing comedy for four years on
paper but two years come on [ __ ]
yeah you want to do this about two and a
half years come on [ __ ]
and then they featured me for lorry kill
Martin
and I didn't go back to bald I was like
I found the hole right there in my back
well I first found my real niche like I
was just going up there and trying to
tell jokes and finding yourself and then
one Monday I got back with the stripper
she invited me to her house we had
tremendous sex and looked when he asked
came to mouthal [ __ ] thing Thanks
she went we went grocery shopping I had
a hundred and seventy-five the house to
my name groceries were a hundred and
forty and she looked at me and I paid
four hundred four dollars worth of
groceries I had 35 miles went back to
her house she made me turkey burgers
with mushrooms and onions with something
on the side of salad it was 6:30 my
clothes were there I was on a stay we
were back together and she started
talking about some guy she had [ __ ]
and we got into an argument and I'll
never forget I said can I at least get
half the money from the groceries so she
goes [ __ ] you
last time I paid for groceries so here I
am at the underground with my luggage
behind the counter everything I owned
dirty final hauls in my pocket know what
is sleep and I went up down a Monday
night and I said two or three jokes Lee
and I just went into this for years I
had that tape I gave it to Joe Rogan it
was one of the first times that Joe Diaz
came out that wasn't a friend he came
out and went right back it like he got
scared when I saw it on tape it
petrified man I went up there and said
exactly a what I got one up then tried
to be cute
and all of a sudden I go who the [ __ ]
my kid I want to kill this [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah I just went on a rant I destroyed
that room you know and I forget the bit
I got from it like I got a joke from it
I'm dating a stripper everyone loved
everything was going great then I ran
out of money
something like stupid and I just ran
with it and then I wanted to the [ __ ]
ball and chain something
and I wanted to why and this is when o j
was hot like that yeah 95 over going
into wide now I know why he killed that
[ __ ]
and people like ah but that was the
first time that I had done copy it took
me four years to really found my voice
and then I said that's never gonna
happen again
like I was so scared of that guy coming
out they took five years for that guy to
come out again changes so you have it it
just never the diet the day comes out on
the way home you're like oh what the
[ __ ] happened tonight so you know you
have it you can go into that gear you
can go to that spot so yeah that wasn't
the comedy underground yes on a Monday
night
that was the open ye night has a thick
bade sweater on would like stripe on
I'll never forget that I'll never forget
somebody saying hey I taped that said me
looking I'm going no you didn't and
they're like yeah I have a few at the
end of the week nice somebody taped that
set for me and I popped it in and tears
rolled down with yes like I was like oh
my god I care was that person that Club
was the Seattle was just a great spot
for me to start and that's who you first
got on stage that was pretty much yeah I
mean when I moved back here I graduated
college Arizona State never did anything
other than an acting class then I came
back here in summer of 93 and it took a
workshop at UCLA with Pauly Shores
sister knowing that the Comedy Store
sponsored it so as a way for me to get
into the comedy store I knew that it
could it was a way to possibly get seen
so did the workshop and then every
Wednesday I Drive by the Comedy Store
one day maybe I'll be in there and then
I did my graduating workshop there in
the original room it was packed I did
well
people are giving business cards I felt
like it was a comedian then I did one
open mic out in Chatsworth like next
night and it was a typical open mic
which was like a not a wake up call but
I didn't want to go through that being
that I'm from the valley I just got done
playing baseball as
to be hard for me to have somebody
probably not from the valley running the
show giving me like a kid you know
whatever you know yeah well you know I
knew the open I just didn't want I did
one open mic to know it wasn't for me
and I went back to UCLA and I took the
business a comedy class I want to learn
all about comedy and then the guy said
if you want to do stand-up you got to
get out of it Los Angeles that's what he
told him he taught the class Danny
Robinson APA no [ __ ] yeah do you still
see him from time to time time to time
time to time you see ptosis all of the
end yeah yeah yeah good guy he he
represents Tiffany Haddish oh he does
yeah there you go well he taught the
workshop and he said it's good to get
away and then I looked into going either
back to Phoenix where I had friends but
no real feel for supportive art I didn't
feel that vibe when I went to school
there but my aunts and uncles lived up
in Seattle and they said come up just
come up to Seattle they support the Arts
up here and then they had the Northridge
earthquake in 94 I was working at Macy's
Bullock's over there Topanga
promenade mall I got in the earthquake
happened got in the car and left and
drove up to Seattle stayed with my
family out out in Bellevue area and then
I just jumped into doing the open mikes
at the comedy underground just jumped
into it mean people then I got a job at
the comedy underground learning all I
just want to learn everything about come
but I do it the company of just sat
people you know on Fridays and Saturdays
clay with you know was the gent ran it
you know with the long hair I still talk
to look oh really
isn't like in Asia or something he's an
Asian disease you something yeah he
taught me all about clay Jones yeah clay
Joe he was a interesting guy and he
taught me all about how the club ran and
all the stories behind it and I just
learned about how to seed a room run a
room see a three-person non showcase
show I learned about comedy there in
Seattle and luckily there's some great
comedians and there was just you know
coffee shops that's where I learned to
write I learned to drink coffee in
Seattle I just the the the environment
up there was really conducive to being
too
being an artist and then we had the
cable access me and Tina we jumped on
that we did that it was just a big it
was a great community up in Seattle
where I found my voice and then after
three years because I started up there I
could tell like I was only getting maybe
guest spots but I was itching to get out
I was itching I made kind of like found
my voice I wanted to do more and then
you told me Joey you said Brody you got
to go to New York and then I went to New
York and that's where I really like
broke out and found my voice just
talking and walking getting off the
subway the l-train and walking the Lower
East Side with my headphones on and
visualize and feeling like yeah I'm cool
okay like give him myself that
confidence because I had some based off
the cable access show and mostly that
because I wasn't really getting great
spots at the comedy underground I mean
maybe a guest I wasn't their guy and I
understood but when I went to New York I
felt that energy and I really honed my
voice doing the Lower East Side shows
and then I barked at the Comedy Cellar
but I was so because I thought it would
lead to get in a spot but but I was
intimidated by SD so I never really
asked her how to get on I was
intimidated but I saw the Comedy Cellar
bar come in so I knew Dave Attell Judah
Gaffigan Todd Barry Maher and I saw how
that room was run but still wasn't doing
it but New York is where you know I
started doing shows though some
alternative shows with Todd Baron Mayer
and Dave Chappelle and I was holding my
own I just felt like I can come back
home to Los Angeles and I have a
marketable skill and my friends were
coming out here that I met in New York
or working for show so when I got here
in 2000 I had a place to stay at a car I
knew my way around and then boom I got a
spot on CBS late-night Late Late Show at
Kilbourne I did a premium blend and then
I got best damn sports show and then the
rest is history so if you want to say
that but I kind of like New York is
where I really like I honed it and as a
kid growing up here in the valley I was
just I was just I wanted to go to New
York City I wanted
that gritty skyscraper energy and that's
what it gave them you told me to go
there that's where I like just started
talking like that's why I did surf
reality because they weren't into jokes
it was like talking so I talked about
what was on my mind getting mad about
just New York stuff or what have you so
I did that and then warm up was helped
me professionally like being around
celebrities or whatever and then just
doing shows and then going for it it's
like this is the major leagues now once
you're here in LA to have thoughts like
I'm not confident what are they gonna
think and I don't have that it's like I
can't this is it so I feel like I've
done pretty good in terms of like I have
a lot of like oh my resume is wide and
vast I just haven't really capitalized
on one thing and have done that whatever
that one thing may be well I gotta tell
you something
elmo's how to tear my eyelids a real
legend cial because you know I had this
discussion with Duncan on his podcast
how I would love to tell you there's not
a god I would love to tell people that
there's not a god or a higher force or a
higher power but meet them on the
Seattle was a pivotal point in my life
like pivotal like looking back and even
though I got arrested six times right
you know it was the pivotal point in my
life like it taught me it took me
completely out of my comfort zone I
still remember going to the underground
I got into town at 1:00 in the morning
on Friday night slept got up in 931 and
got eggs and took a bus down to the
county underground mmm-hmm and just
looked in there there was leaving it was
swamis yeah Swami's upstairs I was
downstairs and all I wanted to do was to
figure out how to get a spot and I was
there the bar was closed and I'm looking
through the [ __ ] glass and my heart's
pumping
cuz I met the [ __ ] calm the other
girl
and then I went back Sunday and they
told me to come back on Monday and like
that was the happiest day of my life
like that [ __ ] Sunday when they said
come back on Monday and sign up for the
open mic and I signed up the guy was
great to me and I gave him I dropped
today em records and they doesn't yeah
we'll put you up and I was like I do not
believe there's some at the colony on
the ground I can't do not believe this
and then a kid walked in with a Boston
Red Sox hat on backwards I know who that
was it was Josh wolf everything loved
just latched on don't I said you got
your from these clothes yeah you gotta
fill me in on what's going on here I
came on too heavy to Josh I'm a man
being like kind of intimidated yeah I
called him every day for a week like
what the [ __ ] you know call me back you
know but I was just so ready and then
Karl woman Haven I will assistant
manager I will all be it's like uh I'll
be inventing for the rest of my life I
could never say no to him if he calls me
for something because that year and a
half with him was an education you know
that I was not gonna get in Denver I was
not getting that time the education in
Denver Seattle newly accommodate the
Arts they there's a reason there's a
reason why all those companies are up
there the contest took me to a different
level
yep just doing the contest over those
coming in like six to seventh took me to
a different level and then being there
like being the feature Act every six
weeks every six weeks I was a feature
mm-hmm you know I knew how to manipulate
John Fox
I knew out a minute be like giggles I
knew how to you know get Bellingham I
had a mom rotation on Monday I would fax
Pat Wolfson I would fax Donna Reed in
Ealing I would fax our berto who booked
the music box
I remember downtown you know in those
days Monday at 9:00 I was already on the
corner I didn't have a fax machine
giving them a corner of fax a cover
sheet and a [ __ ] schedule
fake fake schedule completely fake
bogus you know thank God a lot of comedy
clubs didn't have web pages in those
days right but I wouldn't I like make up
[ __ ] dates like don't give me this
like let's say this week here if I was
home I would say I'm in Caroline's in
New York I would just flat-out lie on
the resume and then leave three weeks
open so they could see I was open
hopefully they give me a Thursday at the
music box or sadly Alberto booked two
things that Wilson had like four things
Donna Reed had like eight thing Ron
Reed's wife well she's a manager Ron's a
man if she was a manager but she Laura
Laura Krakow rest in peace that [ __ ]
had to yeah Josh she had Josh but that
[ __ ] had 15 rooms and those days she
had 15 to 20 rooms she had those two
Mexican rooms that one room up in Kent
yeah she had rooms Jack see she didn't
really book me I wasn't booked me but I
got back at it I would call her and ask
her for guest spots and I could feel her
[ __ ] is tightening up with alcohol
because she hated me with every piece of
her heart she hated me all the way down
to her toes but I would call three times
a week I'd done whatever was the name
was it Donna the Laura Laura
I know mrs. Crockett Joey Diaz but I
could hear her go I'm gonna go down to
your club tonight
don't guess but it's not okay with you
she would not pay me she never paid me
and done but till today I thanked her
because her hatred made me a better
comic there you go I proved myself to
her that I was better than she was
she might have hated me but I did a free
spot in her rooms three nights a week
and the club all if you say why don't
you work here because she won't book I
mean Seattle was like that you know it's
like they're a if you're a big big guy
you know an Italian guy Seattle and
Italy it's like ditalion Stu different
anger well you know the thing about that
I learned early on the thing I learned
early on was that and this was a
no-brainer I think it was a guy named
there was a magician who worked the
Tribble
run and he came in on a Tuesday and he
was a sweetheart of a guy and I had him
sleep over this is my first week at come
first year at comedy at this point I was
probably doing comedy nine months and I
let him sleep on my house I was divorced
and I had two bedrooms and the triple
runs in those days went Tuesday night
Boulder Wednesday night year off so a
feature at pickup $50 cash I'd have to
pay $40 for a hotel room cuz you were
off write you off so that means you had
us pay for your own hotel Wednesday
night then Thursday was Craig Friday was
gonna sin and Saturday was [ __ ] the
edge of hell Telluride these were hell
these were tough gigs if that the devil
run was a big week Craig Colorado was
the only room that in the thing it said
this room gets active the stage was 30
feet away and there was glass and they
would throw [ __ ] oh really and they said
if something happens if go to your room
lock yourself in and call them a nine
moment I mean the [ __ ] thing it said
would just make you laugh like
underneath the room this in caution this
room gets active so active you know what
I would do in those days will let if the
headliner or the feature were cool I
give him my number say call me when you
check out
you got a consciously upon come all that
and some of those guys at Doug Stanhope
the guy that took cranny Prince's placed
and she throwing the man I had a couple
guys there but one guy said over that
wasn't the funniest guy in the world but
he was a magician comic and he was kind
of a nice guy
mm-hmm he gave me a list of Booker's you
know like those guys I had those sheets
yeah he went to the printing place and
he made like 20 sheets of bookings but
he told me something I said to him do
you think I should go to New York and he
goes why would you want to do that
there's a thousand years in New York you
know there's a thousand years in Boston
because you gotta find the market where
there's nobody else like you can't get
shot you
good you could be unique and people why
that's why when the opportunity for
Seattle came up I was like I'm going
yeah Seattle it's uh this is the same
thing I told you
mm-hmm and it also told this to Mitch
Hedberg oh the reason why I told you
guys this is because they have a
thousand you are here there's a thousand
goofy white guys they don't have that in
New York now they do now they got
everything in the right but not twenty
years ago twenty years ago there was a
lot of guys like me nobody talked to the
audience which is a bad habit that you
pick up in New York you talk to the
audience so the boat the coasts were
different yeah so well I talked the
Hedberg God rest his soul and I told him
there's nobody would like you in New
York
he hit New York went to New York because
there's nobody like you there that's
what you're gonna get love whether
people like you it's no luck I knew when
I saw you that there wasn't nobody like
you in New York at that time yeah now
there's a thousand guys trying to move
Brody Stevens they don't work you follow
me and then they become themselves yeah
you know when we all start we start
being somebody else and we become
ourselves we evolve into ourselves I
just think like comedians I try to send
them to New York City try and spend some
time there go there I I you know move
there I became I lived there for three
years I wasn't going back and forth I
was living there and I got to experience
that New York lifestyle taking the
subway and being you know you could did
it wasn't like who you were was what you
were you know people you were like you
didn't you could do matter what you
looked like New York nobody cared
whereas LA I grew up here in LA I went
to school in Arizona it wasn't it was
not it's completely different from New
York just New York just really opened my
gave me that confidence if you can make
it in New York you can make it anywhere
that's what they say and I just recently
went back to New York last month and I
felt that energy again just walking
around that city and you know getting
out of Los Angeles here getting out of
the valley just getting getting into
that and getting off the internet
getting out of your head walk in that
city and you feel and you walk in you
can it inspires you and and and you
start saying yourself I don't need to
have these meds and s I don't need to
have all these things and overthink it
you jump in and you got a sink or swim
there it's good for you I think
everybody I think most comedians should
strive to live if they can therefore I
did - I could 10 months 10/10 the
beginning and it woke me the [ __ ] up I
didn't let me know who the [ __ ] I was or
what I wanted and what I needed to do to
get to my goals like in that that that's
why I went right back to Denver with a
firecracker on my ass and I went to them
and I worked every night and I took that
work ethic up to Seattle and I just did
Seattle it was double of work right so
now I had double the payload you know no
matter what you do in life you have to
sacrifice man and you have to get out of
your comfort zone to get the way you
want to be whether you're an artist or
[ __ ] you know you're you play the
trumpet but you play the trumpet in
[ __ ] Louisiana not Louisiana in Utah
what's listened to a trumpet Louisiana
you gotta go to a jazz bar in
Minneapolis or a jazz bar New Orleans or
you know a jazz bar in LA you know
sometimes you gotta and then people
can't make that step so they never
fulfill what the [ __ ] they wanted to do
you know I mean when you came in tonight
and you said you got off those meds I
gotta taste something brownie I'm proud
of you thank you
I'm Patti and I'm proud that you know
like you said well whatever I'm calmed
the one thing about me is man I put
myself in the worst case in there and I
told you I said you know and it was a
joke and we laughed you know a couple
years ago you want a rubber room [ __ ]
smart imaginary flies you in a rubber
room saying help there's a fly who's
talking tight I I was combative with the
Filipino nurses at you know they
threatened me with
needle right but I was all I go I don't
need to be here I go I made a mistake go
look on the internet I'm a good guy I
kept telling him like look me up but now
that was a crazy time but I was kind of
like to be honest I yeah I couldn't
believe that I was in the UCLA hospital
I made days to have you were there for
17 though that they wouldn't let me
leave I went from three days to six days
to nine days and basically did you make
any meaningful relationships in there
did you meet anybody in there that
you've contact you know one girl like
attack me over like chocolate ice cream
I didn't was 17 days yeah who knew about
this at the time did your mom know my
mom I mean people knew I think because I
was tweeting about it I I think I just
needed to like dry out because I I went
off those meds cold turkey I made a
mistake I went to Ireland I went to
Montreal they told me to take a victory
lap I'm having fun I actually took a
little less because I wanted to I'd
always had wanted to
it's not maybe be on the lexapro which
is common but I also knew that going to
Dublin and I was researched like okay if
you want to drink a beer maybe cut back
a little bit I cut back and then I got
sick in Montreal right after it was like
a two-week trip all together and then
they gave me a the z-pak and I had strep
throat and then they gave me the z-pak I
felt better and I said I feel great I
don't need these I don't think I need
the meds anymore I'm like through this
period and then but here's the thing I
was Jess I'm still having about 17 days
that I did not like One Flew Over the
Cuckoo's Nest well you know what it was
like everything about this I wrote I
have my notes somewhere but I felt I
mean I delight we do a short film by a
17 day stint and then you'll be brutally
honest like what you did [ __ ] man that's
the secret right there if we can
recreate play ping-pong I smoked meth
meth all cigarettes with methyl methyl
menthol it's menthol
listen to radio watch TV
you talk to me buddy we just um not
really but I had a lot of visitors a lot
of friends who came by
Zach came by Nick Kroll Steve Rannazzisi
I don't even know you were in debt this
is great this is the first yeah I had a
Booker they were like bringing people in
you know if we could have got you in
worked in and where were you a UCLA
right over the hospital that Ronald
Reagan
I guess psychiatric ward but I wasn't I
because I've felt that way before
well not necessarily I just know not to
go you just can't do it I want on the
trigger that time I think when I came
back so I I want what do you need to
avoid to stay off the meds and on that
back there what is the roadie package
back at you sir oh it's a flies talking
to Chinese people
it's feast or famine yeah torture food I
don't know I mean I should probably have
some like a support system with this but
I'm being my own advocate I know my body
I'm mature I know choices I'm not saying
that I won't ever go back on a
medication we'll see but so far I'm
trying to implement a life skill
you know like socializing booking
working being a being an adult and
taking supplements doing my comedy
believing in myself
I'm just calmer if my body feels better
of this I'll say that except for me to
not go back I mean I never had a problem
before or after I had a reaction to
these medications is what I guess I was
never headed like this guys I was never
gonna be like something like that I went
off um it was just and I was agitated
it's like I attacked a guy at a start
couple Starbucks a 7-eleven I was like
road rage guy but I was just but I got
banned from this table cool no comment
no I know here's what happened I felt
when I got back I think my friend saw me
and they were surprised
like Oh Brody you're not yourself but I
felt like okay I'm you know I feel
better I'm not the audience warm-up guy
I'm Brody now I got this show on HBO
happening I have good things happening
so I came back confident and I think
people were a little like taken aback
that oh he's confident we're not used to
this guy because I did the TMZ show they
loved it I did it that day I did a
taping I did a show at UCB and I did
fine I was just out of my character they
weren't used to it and then when they
questioned me then I became defensive
and my my I became agitated so and this
was like a first time if it happening
and then you tie in the Twitter that's
the other thing I that outlet to go you
know to lash out but I was also I mean I
I did stuff on Twitter also you know
saying like feo the Twitter thing was
what I had heard that you were cracking
on Twitter I did hear that
I heard something about a roof no roof
no no I was never I never I felt great
with nothing you were gonna jump with
nothing that you climbed something no no
no climbing I didn't know climbing I
don't know you have a zip line would
leave you took it down I don't [ __ ]
know they did go on Twitter and I was
lashing out but part of us cuz because I
did TMZ and these guy and I felt like I
did a good job and these guys are saying
I'm out of my mind
f you I know what I'm doing and I just
had all this confidence and not being on
the medication to like hold me back I
was I was basically manic that's all I
mean not that's all but that's what was
happening to me and it was freaking
people out so they called the police as
opposed to maybe saying hey Brody
maybe we'll go to let's go to you know
go to Santa Barbara for a few days and
chill it could have been handled that
way I looking back on it to be honest
with you because I've learned since like
you could believe me if I take Red Bulls
and do something I know I could like get
agitated I was just I was uh yeah I just
typical signs of stopping the meds Colt
ekiden could have happened to anybody so
I don't feel like I have that's
something that would
in me whether gonna happen I don't think
so
I would hope not I don't know we'll see
how I deal with with stress that's why
podcasting that's why having a support
system you know I started doing the
periscopes after all this to check in
and be more you know and be more present
and walking making appointments
periscopes are brilliant that's
brilliant I didn't know you used it
therapeutic Lee also I did that a little
bit after yeah like this was like a year
or two after but definitely like walking
became therapeutic like getting out of
the house I learned to get out walk and
go to the Starbucks people like
associate me with going to Starbucks
that's because I walk to it I made it
known like I'm known for being out so
you're forcing again you're doing what
we discussed early on you're stopping
the [ __ ] before he was shows up
yeah you're stopping depression before I
even shows up you're stopping your mind
from going there before they even take
you there you know which is always
that's I've learned when your mind is
taking you there to take it somewhere
else
trust me took me 30 years I'm no
psychotherapist I just know if I wait if
I go to bed and I wake up at 3:00 in the
morning with something on my mind I did
that for years and I would go insane and
pace and then one done I took a little
book out and I wrote down what I was mad
about go smoke go to make a cheese come
back and read it you'll fall right to
sleep but a lot of this depression for
me if I'm susceptible to some of that I
am so it's I think it's a lot of its
career fine it's like that sort of thing
it's not these are not irrational
thoughts so some of these thoughts about
like money or career I am I I can
rectify them by taking action so for me
to go hey I'm gonna I need a pill or I
go need to talk to somebody no you need
to go book a podcast you need to go show
your face you need to go for a walk you
need to sign up for a class so I'm
implementing
you know those activities to stave it
off and I you know I get down on myself
I've always been someone who y'all got
we can all do I've always been that but
I'll say this like I'm lucky I'm
grateful that I have the that that I've
made
you know I've I've been able to do
comedy and I can perform at The Comedy
Store I can go places because it's it's
an outlet it's not therapy it's
therapeutic and I know it helps other
people as well and I think today with it
being so negative out there and if I can
share some of my some of my philosophies
without jamming it down their throat but
baseball's fun I've been around
successful baseball successful TV show
successful comedians podcasts I'm
sharing that and then the Comedy Store
being the hottest club and if you have
your name on the marquee and you're have
a spot at the Comedy Store that means
something and I know that and I try to
share with people how I might think you
know like I'll even joke like I got a
you didn't laugh at that joke well I get
free Red Bull you don't laugh at that
joke I park for I park wherever I want
so why don't you do what I do it's kind
of a joke but it is a joke but I think
that yeah I'm lucky I'm lucky but I'm
just you know how lucky we are very
lucky very very lucky just the fact that
we were together in Seattle mm-hmm did
you ready people grab a pen and a piece
of paper 1997 even before I got there in
96 I got there 90 just for its 90 its
2018 so we've known each other we've
been in the struggle the 22 years mm-hmm
we've been apart for four of those years
you were in New York mm-hmm that's we're
very lucky we're very lucky there's a
lot of people that we were up there and
there was one night in that 16 list I'll
never forget
listen man when I'm in that [ __ ] hole
folks home and my memories gone and I'm
dying I'm gonna think of those Monday
nights they were great they were very
very special to me there were your whole
week that's what people don't understand
that's what sucks about doing comedy in
that way that you don't have a home club
they you don't get pushed apart by your
peers because of the Houston on Monday
nights you had a show up or every Monday
wouldn't do five minutes track you're
Peters forced you because inside you
look at that [ __ ] bad mm-hmm so you
know we had that we had that that every
Monday you had a show for three minutes
yeah you could show up with some of the
shaded in last week but you better show
up with something to [ __ ] kill that
was your goal on Monday two minutes he
only had six minutes right yeah six
eight and then the closer that's 15th
oh no the open mic you'd get six apiece
it was him at six five five six light at
five six because they were training you
for the Seattle Comedy Competition okay
remember let's see how commonly
competitions five six the first week
light at five you gotta be off by six oh
you got a point dinging away so they
trained you for that if to do the open
mic system so I think just for that
alone if I don't wake up tomorrow we
still had the opportunity I'm growing
together going fall I mean I got locked
up in jail for 30 days in Seattle you
got putting a loony bin down here for 17
days it's look if what happens we all
had our [ __ ] shortcomings but what's
important is that we're still in LA
we're still doing smut was still
relevant and it goes back to those
Monday nights yeah if you go home
tonight smoke a joint you really think
about what we learned on those Monday
nights just porch from Reno
Oh Oh taking her pills and eating a
pizza and her nachos we would eat him
nachos burrito was the local [ __ ] good
nachos they're at a geyser around few of
us we'd build the bartender loud
I stole his girlfriend and clays girl
for nods Maryland sitting there in the
Monday night open mic two checks like
this
waitresses I think I'm the hot asian
there was a hot asian waitress on Monday
nights yeah I remember that was Bill's
girlfriend and then we'd go upstairs and
that bartender [ __ ] hated me but the
hi Anthony Anthony but I had a tab in
there I still remember go on upstairs
the same Seahawks all the baseball
towels and all the baseball teams it was
uh and you know what
there was no ATM card there was no car
there was no HBO
there was no Netflix I lived in an
office a little bit smaller than this
one on the floor with it with three or
four towels is a pillow a half a blanket
then my clothes next to me on the floor
and those are the happiest time is my
[ __ ] life going down on a Monday
night yeah and then we leave there and
go somewhere else who had cages they
have another open mic come on oh yeah
right I didn't I didn't really do that Y
bar it was yeah sound we'd go there they
had chicks and cages that was always
never why you're on stage why you're a
state that's always great it's a it's a
list and then we got the takoma contest
yeah you've ever known Tacoma crossroads
crossroads she contacted me recently
over I like to say hello she's still
around so listen man you know when you
get a check now or where something good
happens I want you to remember that you
earned all this you there's no reason to
ever end up for me what I did I got it
something just left looks but everything
goes back to those Monday night in
Seattle so I'm thankful I had that and I
had that seen and done before Seattle
but nothing beats my comedy a brand in
those two years those 18 months I didn't
see how made my mind become a comma and
I'll never ever ever forget that you
were part of that you thank you
yeah just they were so into your
with the coffeehouse the weather and the
late-night diners and just the
characters in the scene and the
cable-access shows and they watched it
Seattle really supported that stuff you
couldn't do that in a Los Angeles or and
it was it was a big city but it was a
small city and it was you just knew
you're doing something right it was on
that and in Seattle you know it needed
the I guess grunge was just dying out
but there's just something to let's
think of all those guys were there at
that point mitch hedberg you myself Josh
wolf Craig Gass all those comedians
they're still working like they do the
cruise ships they're do all the
corporate stuff Seattle David Crowe
David Crowe my god Hawaiian kid Kermit
appear happy Oh Vince founds whale are
still around
yeah he lives in Santa Monica I don't
know if he's doing comedy anymore so I'm
on feet an ooh hip dude he yeah it's
talking about on Facebook but there's
just characters in Seattle that you
wouldn't get I would say like yeah you
said I may be a Denver you wouldn't get
or fina or get Alice so when I think
about a lot is the cook dick at the end
the ground downstairs with the long hair
I he was if guys he was one of the most
interesting guys I haven't met we don't
time to go into him now but what was his
name
I have to call Josh okay yeah I remember
I remember his face I remember his long
hair and the nights that I couldn't make
the bus back the bell though ever Josh
little view Bellevue
I would space stay with him okay and I
can't tell you Oh every time I stayed
with him it was a different adventure
first he had first of all ya know he he
lived in the house two blocks from the
thing he had two broken windows to air
I'm average slowin and you know by the
window there was like three inches of
snow turned his land I'm on the corner
with ten blankets on my Jaqueline do you
know I felt I I got so [ __ ] high in
his apartment one night that you got to
go take a show cuz he lived in a
warehouse uh-huh you had to pull the
thing up in the elevator go upstairs and
there was
people on the floor but one shower and
one bathroom and that one day I was
walking towards the bathroom I just
remember this and I [ __ ] was hungover
and I was so [ __ ] up to that before
that before I went in the shower I paid
a passed-out and went through this
sheetrock
there was an imprint of me uh-huh going
through the [ __ ] sheetrock till this
day it's probably still me just tipped
over and broke the [ __ ] wall but it
was them for you could still see my head
where I went through the sheetrock and
he woke me up and they threw me in the
shower Jesus Christ crazy times before
social media before all of this
technology was it was a simpler time it
was it's tough to be a man oh man a lot
of information a lot of I've seen in the
last three years I've seen I feel a lot
more people go crazy then I've ever seen
in my life I can tell them on two hands
and you think if you think it has
something to do with social media that's
one of the conduits for I think that
it's rolled around it's everything
that's going on social media the way the
news is portrayed the way people are
acting the political climate dog I think
that it's just people losing their minds
I see it every day and it's sad it's sad
but hey I'm happy you're off the meds
thank you and I may go back on but we're
good now right now yeah bounced balance
you're Zack lights system with me thank
you
port system with Josh Moore yep you have
the Comedy Store and that's the most
important thing man I'm happy you're
still doing your thing you're always
welcome out of the church Church of
what's happening and [ __ ] it keep doing
what you're doing if next time you go to
if next time god forbid I'll go this oh
your visit okay we'll get you booked
[ __ ] I'll smuggle some mint to keep
you saying I don't wanna cook something
keep you going
I love you Brody Stephens thank you for
coming on the church brother Thank You
Joey
Thank You Lee I was Brody Stephens hope
you enjoyed it he made us laugh
we talked about [ __ ] then a couple
days later babbling they sent me a bunch
of [ __ ] how Fox books and [ __ ] for
our Fox tour he was a [ __ ] celebrity
and poor [ __ ] Momo but anyway guys I
want to thank you for a great great
great 1999 2019 I'm sorry that's how
[ __ ] up this [ __ ] cookie got me
real quick before we end this show
another company I truly believe in for
2024 you if you haven't gone with them
yet is on it whether you start with the
club bells an 18 pound kettlebell of 35
pound kettlebell I got a 35 pounds got
about I do swing through the cleans with
Turkish get ups with it you know what do
I do three sets of each but I'm over I'm
56 I'm just trying to keep it together
you're young
start now go with the Alpha brand for
starters it's a nootropic it clears your
thinking it helps your focus and the
most important thing is they're running
a raffle you get a ticket you win you
win the haunted experience if you don't
like the [ __ ] alpha brain keep it
tell them you don't like and they'll
sing you the money back tell me one
company that does day you think when you
go to Popeyes and stand on line over
there if you don't like that disgusting
chicken sandwich they'll give you the
money back [ __ ] no and it is the way to
go Island is the future Islanders your
future for 2022 get your life together
you're thinking together whether you
travel and you're getting sickly to get
the Schrute export the shrimp take
immune so go 200 calm right now press in
church BAM get 10% off you all are
delivered right to your [ __ ]
crib and last but not least it's
something I believe in for 2020 if
you're not starting a year off with a
clean [ __ ] it's gonna be a bad year
for you trust me no more spicy ass or
why so we got a portable bidet you like
but George and it caused me thousands no
it's not how long does she started
79,000 they come in all different colors
sizes you know you can fit him right
into your bathroom equation you're like
why why do why do I need a bidet why
because you use in paper some [ __ ]
apocalypse those walking around
right now with no tree because you're
wiping your [ __ ] [ __ ] did you
think of that and it's easy to install
you install it yourself it takes ten
minutes and it uses the water that runs
for you to shave and brush it peaking on
tap into your toilet water ooh
and once this bidet is down you don't
know what it's like that will take a
nice 1820 and [ __ ] sit back in the
sprinkler and water in your [ __ ] and
know it's going deep into the cave of
your ass like those twelve little tyke
kids they got lost in Thailand
understand me that's a joke people don't
worry about nothing anyway
no dirty ass hose no itchy ass those no
[ __ ] skid marks no UTI is no [ __ ]
hemorrhoid believed nothing
why because you got a bad day and that's
the future and that's the way to go you
got in any other country the days of
popular here you gotta cut ten trees and
shame it and then [ __ ] scrap your ass
and god forbid you run out of toilet
paper
then you gotta use the paper and the
[ __ ] thing that's like you might as
well take sandpaper the [ __ ] brush
your [ __ ] ass buddy how do we get the
[ __ ] sandpaper let's just stick to
the topic at hand here but days hello do
she go - hello - she calm right now look
at the great selection that they have to
offer you get back to me with this okay
save a tree wash you [ __ ] hello - she
calm / Church get 10% off and that's how
this [ __ ] ends all right I want
to thank hello - she calm and I also
want to thank Allah Tom for a great year
but most importantly I want to thank you
guys for your accomplishments and for
your failures and for acknowledging them
and to keep coming back and listening
and supporting us every week you know
we're here you know we love you from
[ __ ] hook the J bish to the Lingus
the long Rose Inca - Jeremy slit I love
all you [ __ ] Kerr and Michael
and this is just off the top of my
[ __ ] head you understand me I love
you guys have a great [ __ ] week I'll
do a couple periscopes just to tease you
but besides that we'll be back
January 6 ready to [ __ ] rock alright
blue cheese with wings or go [ __ ] your
mother
kick this [ __ ] mule II have a great
week happy New Year to you and all your
family and made 2020 be the year you
wait not kick it Lee